[Music]
yesterday as we mentioned was
Valentine's Day hope you had a nice one
I did I spent Valentine's Day with the
most romantic person I know I'm talking
of course about our shows associate
producer Jordan slansky there he is
right there yeah Charles Manson like
stare I know yeah anyway you know
sometimes on the show in the past I've
hung out with Jordan and I thought I'd
I'd hang out with him on Valentine's Day
so we got together at a local bar to
talk about love and just chat about it
chart about love romance and well here's
what happened hey I'm here at Timmy
Nolan's tavern and it's just a couple of
blocks away from the Warner Brothers
Studio and I'm sitting with one of our
associate producers Jordan slansky you
the only associate producer there other
ones I'm the only one okay where's an
associate producer do okay are you a
romantic person I believe I am a
romantic person when you first came to
our show you were quivering nerd what
happened I find with greater life
experience there's a greater awareness
of the outside world and the inside
world what are you reading from Sarah
sir a script back here how do you dress
to attract a woman what do you like to
wear I feel like it's most important
that you're comfortable with yourself
you dress with something that will make
you feel comfortable and confident right
and the rest is irrelevant right well
that so not this because you look like
Jerry Van Dyke on coach
very confident you could get married one
day or do you prefer the life of a
swinging single I think it's a fallacy
to expect that you can predict your
future but these are things I anticipate
my time I can predict your future you're
fired
you know my questions succinctly I'm
drinking and it's I think 11 o'clock in
the morning it's never a good sign I
want to hear what what turns you on
physically about a lady do you like it
when they're showing a little got the
headlights on there's a little cleavage
the puppies are on display in the window
they put their moccasins out to be
cleaned by the hotel staff do you like
it when the the two bald priests are
staring out the highway and those on the
bus with eul's what do you is that do
you like that kind of look I find that
there's a general consistency between
the way somebody looks on the outside
and the way they are in the instant you
talk about the inside one more time and
pull your face off with my hands is this
something you would ever give a girl you
were interested in possibly really it's
not as romantic as you think this is a
bear that was born with its heart
outside its chest I look at the Bears
like I kill me die my heart
no no fair no no anyway I hey take it
easy now you and I have talked about a
lot of hypotheticals I'd like to see
what a woman thinks so I've asked one of
our researcher Sarah Bruno to join us
Sarah try your approach on Sarah how are
you you know this is the first Irish bar
I've been to in Los Angeles and I find
that it's really different than the ones
that there were in New York it's almost
more upscale and I didn't even know they
were popular here now what do you think
of that approach very talkative I
haven't been to an Irish bar I've
noticed this I've done that what are you
an opera singer
I think our notes for Jordan are say les
don't shop it kids gap physically
relaxed open come on yeah yes yes look
at that see those parts going join you
back to your post look what happened to
you naturally you've contracted and
that's important to being opposed that
makes you're comfortable and relaxed
sure I know this this is a Tai Chi
position it's called rod up the ass
thank you well there you have it
nobody's learned anything and I'm
drinking at 11 o'clock